private fundraiser at his Maro Lago resort
in Florida.
Donald Trump was actually asked about his
spending and his explosion of the national
debt.
And according to people in the room, he said,
quote, who the hell Al
cares about the budget?
We're going to have a country now, I've been
telling you for years, this is bigger than
Trump, that the debt and deficits are a political
football.
That's all that they are.
Our elected officials don't really care about
debt and deficit as long as we're going into
debt for the things they want to spend money
on.
And of course, historically, even though Republicans
are the so-called deficit Hawks, Republicans
are the ones who increase the deficit and
thus more quickly increase the national debt
as well.
And in fact, under Barack Obama deficit growth
slowed while under Donald Trump, it has absolutely
exploded.
And there is Trump at his Mar-a-Lago resort
in Florida telling donors behind closed doors.
Who the hell cares about the budget?
We're going to have a country.
The annual, uh, the Trump annual deficit passed
$1 trillion in 2019 and Donald Trump had promised
the opposite.
Trump promised that he would get us a surplus
so big that the debt itself would start shrinking
and completely disappear within eight years.
Now, only someone who is extremely gullible
or knows nothing at all about the debt and
deficit would have even for a second considered
that that might've actually been something
that would happen.
Donald Trump also promised that his tax cuts
would so acutely grow the economy, that the
deficit would shrink as a result of new economic
productivity.
That also has not happened.
Some Republicans may be believed him, others
didn't, but they didn't care because a lot
of them don't actually care.
And per MSNBC, Donald Trump has now added
two point $6 trillion to the national debt
in just three years.
That's more than Barack Obama added during
his entire second term.
The truth is that even Republicans know that
the deficit in and of itself doesn't actually
matter.
Here's a funny video of a reporter, John Carl
asking at a briefing, Hey, you know, Trump
said he'd eliminate the debt.
What happened with all of that?
Check out the answer
questions.
One.
You mentioned what the president promised
during the campaign during the campaign.
He also promised that he would eliminate the
national debt within eight years.
And as you know, I did that at the end of
his first year was that 20 trillion last year
it went to 21 trillion last month, 22 trillion.
So what happened to that promise?
I mean the president has added historically
large numbers to the national debt.
Instead of keeping a promise to actually pay
it off
again in the last administration nearly doubled
the national debt.
And when this president ran for office, he
made a commitment to the American people that
he wouldn't attempt to tackle the debt within
eight years.
This president did that the very first year
that he came to office by sending forth a
budget that balanced within 10 years.
So wait, Trump promised to try to do this
in eight years, proposed a ridiculous budget
that would have done it in 10 and that's considered
an answer to the question.
And what matters are really more detailed
questions that don't get asked questions like
what are we spending on that is growing the
deficit?
Are we growing the deficit because we are
paying for health care or education or is
it because we're paying for weapons as an
example?
Are we growing the deficit or um, uh, increasing
our national debt in a way that improves the
wellbeing of the average American?
Or are we just like going to war with the
countries in the middle East?
What portion of our GDP is the deficit?
Because remember, the rod dollars of deficit
in a vacuum doesn't really tell us anything.
We need to compare it to the size of the economy.
What kind of deficit spending has a high multiplier
economically versus a lower economic multiplier?
We've talked about that term before.
I won't go into it now, but again, when we
go back to the importance that Republicans
themselves place on this issue, they expose
themselves time and again and reveal that
they don't actually care about the debt and
the deficit beyond it being a tool that they
can use to attack Democrats when it's convenient.
This is bigger than Trump.
It really is in a way, even though Trump said
this behind closed doors and probably didn't
intend for it to become public, Trump is being
more honest than most of them.
When he says, who cares about the budget?
When we have a country in the sense that that
means debt and deficit don't matter as long
as we're doing the things that I want to do
and that the people who are going to vote
for me believe that I should be doing or want
me to do any Republican when Republicans are
in power, does not care about the deficit.
Any Republican when there is a democratic
president believes that the out of control
spending is the number one problem and that
we can somehow cut our way to prosperity and
a better middle middle-class and a better
functioning economy.
It's a farce and I appreciate even if it's
behind closed doors, Donald Trump just saying
who cares about it?
And then of course, reminder, anytime we talk
about this, we have to continue to drill this
repeatedly.
We never hear this question asked by Republicans
except for like the occasional Rand Paul libertarian.
We never hear the question, but how would
we pay for this war?
Remember when it looked like we might be going
to war with Iran a couple of weeks ago?
I think Rand Paul said something about how
much it would cost, although it might've just
been about like his non-interventionist stuff
that he was complaining.
Uh, but there's no questions from Republicans
about can we afford war with Iran?
What would be the cost?
Where are we going to get the money?
What about the deficit?
What about the debt?
And yet we hear all the time, we can't afford
health insurance.
We can't afford free public college.
We can't afford to pay for maternity, maternity
leave or paid sick time or whatever the case
may be.
It is merely a political football used when
it is convenient.
Don't for a second think that it is anything
other than that.